Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
36 ans.
Et 18 ans à la police
de Bruxelles-Capitale à Ixelles.
J’ai vu changer certaines choses.
Mais je pense qu’aujourd’hui, nous faisons
de mieux en mieux, sans être parfaits.
Mais je vois aussi que la vitesse
n’a jamais été aussi élevée.
Un mauvais jugement
ou même une erreur professionnelle
peut avoir des conséquences qui perdent
tout sens des proportions.
Il y a une chose dont je suis certain
c’est qu’aujourd’hui, nous vivrons
dans un monde qui est instable,
incertain, complexe et ambigu.
Et [j’ignore] si l’arrivée des réseaux
sociaux est un obstacle,
ou plutôt une aide.
Permettez-moi de vous expliquer
comment ça a commencé pour moi.
Je me souviens comme si c’était hier
comment j’ai expliqué à la psychologue
du service de recrutement
que je voulais entrer à la police
pour aider les gens.
C’était une pensée noble,
mais je n’étais pas conscient
qu’aider l’un peut limiter l’autre.
Je donne un exemple :
les gens veulent des rues
en toute sécurité
et par exemple, un stationnement
sur un trottoir n’en fait pas partie.
Aujourd’hui, je passe d’une infraction
à l’autre et certains applaudissent
mais d’autres considèrent que j’ai vendu
mon âme au portefeuille de l’État.
Au début de ma carrière, je faisais
ce que j’avais si bien appris.
Je cherchais du réconfort dans
la couverture qui m’est donnée
par les textes légaux.
On dirait même que je n'ai pas le choix.
Le Code de la route stipule qu'il est
interdit de se garer sur un trottoir.
Donc, moi, en tant que policier,
je fais partie du pouvoir exécutif.
Donc si j’applique ou je fais appliquer
une loi, je fais du bon travail de police.
La forme me semblait
moins importante que les résultats.
Et je suis même obligé
parce que l’article 29 du Code
d’instruction criminelle m’oblige
à donner avis sur le champ au procureur
du Roi sur chaque crime ou chaque délit
dont je prends connaissance.
Le fait que je connaisse cet article
par cœur est pour le moins remarquable.
Mais en fait, aider les gens,
ça a commencé à prendre forme,
même si je suis sûr qu’à l’époque,
je l’ai formulé maladroitement.
Aujourd’hui, ma motivation,
c’est la recherche de la qualité de vie.
Et pour ça, pour la qualité de vie,
j’ai besoin de vous
parce que je ne sais pas le faire
sans un minimum de confiance mutuelle
ou un respect mutuel.
Donc, je veux donner quelque chose
et je veux aussi quelque chose en retour,
pour me permettre de vous donner
ce que vous méritez,
l’égalité et la justice.
Et donc en fait maintenant,
le mot est tombé : confiance.
Mais comment puis-je l’obtenir ?
Ou bien me la devez-vous par défaut ?
Il y a encore un autre article connu par
beaucoup de policiers par cœur à Bruxelles
et c’est l’article 12 du Règlement
général de la police
qui dit qu’il est interdit de manquer
de respect ou de se montrer agressif
envers une personne qui est habilitée
à faire respecter la loi.
Donc, si je comprends bien cet article,
vous me devez le respect
sans que je fasse quoi que ce soit.
Mais j’ai également déjà lu
des textes «vision »
qui me déclare que la confiance
et le respect sont le résultat
d’un bon travail policier.
Donc, si je comprends bien,
ce texte de vision,
vous ne devez pas le respect jusqu’au
moment où vous avez une bonne raison.
Mais qu’est ce que c’est finalement
un bon travail policier
et comment mesurer la confiance ?
Va-t-on se baser sur les commentaires
qu’on reçoit sur les réseaux sociaux
pour dire que tout va bien ou pas ?
Et en fait, est-ce important
ce que vous pensez de la police ?
Autrement dit, la popularité de la police
est-elle une façon de mesurer
la qualité de son travail ?
(Vidéo) (Musique : Pop Smoke, Invincible)
(Fin de la vidéo)
Une vidéo de la semaine dernière.
Plus de 50 000 sur Tweeter,
plus de 140 000 sur LinkedIn
et beaucoup de publications
dans la presse nationale,
d’ailleurs, que la presse francophone.
Je ne sais pas si c'est une coïncidence.
Mais qu’en est-il de mes principes
de qualité de vie ?
Tout le monde apprécie-t-il
des jeunes qui jouent au foot
dans le piétonnier à Bruxelles ?
Sans même parler d’un policier ?
Et s’il y a quelqu’un qui peut regarder
cette vidéo avec un œil critique,
c’est bien moi parce que le policier
dans la vidéo, Jonathan,
c’est un des meilleurs éléments
de mon équipe.
Et cette vidéo n’a pas été publiée
sans l’accord de la hiérarchie.
Si je me base sur les commentaires,
j’ai envie de penser que tout le monde est
content de cette intervention policière.
Mais j’ai toujours des doutes.
Que fera Jonathan de la prochaine
plainte de nuisances
causées par des jeunes
qui jouent au foot ?
Sera-t-il en mesure de
la juger de façon neutre ?
A-t-il fait une remarque au jeune homme
pour le port du masque
car son masque ne couvre par le nez ?
Ou trouvez-vous que j’exagère après
3 millions de morts du Corona ?
Et regardez où ça se passe.
Le piétonnier est une cible
potentielle d’attaque terroriste.
Pouvons-nous accepter qu’un policier ait
ses yeux sur un ballon de foot
[alors] que le destin peut à nouveau
frapper à la porte à tout moment ?
Je pense que j'ai fait mon point.
Une approche rationnelle montre qu’il y a
une tension entre cette approche
et une approche émotionnelle.
Aujourd’hui, on ne prend plus le temps
de s’attarder sur les choses.
On voit, on ressent et on réagit.
et on répète la série du matin au soir.
La question, ce n’est plus
si nous jouons le jeu ou pas.
Mais la question, c’est si nous
commençons dès le matin,
quand nous ouvrons les yeux,
ou si nous attendons la première
visite aux toilettes, voilà la question.
Moi aussi, je suis content de pouvoir
utiliser les services des médias sociaux,
et en plus, gratuitement, sans payer.
Mais ne vous trompez pas ;
vous êtes le produit et pas le client.
Il y a encore trois choses
qui sont importants.
Première chose : comment attirer
l’attention de quelqu’un ?
Deuxième chose : comment faire en sorte
que cette personne réagisse ?
Et troisième chose : comment
tourner cela en profit ?
Non, pas un profit pour vous, ni pour moi,
mais pour les géants de la technologie.
Aujourd’hui, ça passe d’une vidéo
sur les violences policières
à une vidéo me rappelant que
je dois acheter un nouveau rasoir
et pourquoi pas de la marque Philips
et de ne pas mettre
mon portefeuille trop loin
parce que les terrasses
vont bientôt rouvrir
et pourquoi pas avec une bière,
une Stella ?
Je disais violences policières.
Quand je fais une recherche sur Google
sur «violence policière»
et que je regarde les articles,
j’ai envie de penser qu’une violence
policière est par définition illégale.
Mais c'est faux.
La violence policière est prévue par
la loi, mais bien sûr, elle est limitée.
La légalité, en principe,
est facile à démontrer.
Je donne un exemple.
Si quelqu’un ne sait pas
me prouver son identité,
cette personne peut faire l’objet d’une
privation de liberté pour identification.
Mais si cette personne s’oppose
à cette privation de liberté,
elle peut s’attendre à un contrepoids
de la part de la police
sous forme de contrainte,
qui est un joli mot pour «violence».
En fait, cette case est facile à cocher
ou ne pas cocher,
mais ça devient plus complexe
car la violence utilisée par la police
doit être proportionnelle à la menace.
Je donne un exemple :
quelqu’un dont je sais
qu’il a sa carte d’identité sur lui
mais il refuse de me la donner,
alors je ne peux pas prendre mon arme,
et la pointer sur lui
pour le faire changer d’avis.
Très efficace, mais proportionnellement
pas défendable, donc, c’est interdit.
Mais en réalité, c’est très souvent
beaucoup moins évident.
Imaginons maintenant une menace par geste
avec un poing fermé.
Le poing fermé d’un jeune homme de 12 ans
ne me laisse pas la même impression
que le poing fermé du champion
de Belgique de kickboxing.
Si ce n’était pas encore assez complexe,
on a aussi le principe de la subsidiarité.
Cela signifie que quand il y a une menace
et on [peut] arrêter cette menace
d’une autre façon que la contrainte,
on doit d’abord saisir cette occasion.
Je donne encore un exemple.
Imaginons que quelqu’un me menace
avec une tronçonneuse électrique
et je me trouve à côté de la prise,
dans ce cas, je dois d’abord débrancher
la fiche avant d’utiliser la contrainte.
Mais qui jugera après si je ne suis
pas tellement impacté par la situation ?
Oui, parce que les policiers aussi,
ils peuvent avoir peur.
Qui jugera si je n’ai pas été impacté
au point de ne plus
pouvoir faire la distinction
entre une tronçonneuse électrique
et une à essence.
Je pense que vous avez compris que la
légalité est facile à démontrer, ou pas,
mais proportionnalité et subsidiarité
ouvrent toujours un espace à la discussion
et en fin de réunion,
on n’est jamais d’accord.
Et ça concerne tous les citoyens.
Ce qui était trop violent pour l’un
était trop [faible] pour l’autre.
Et encore une fois,
ça concerne tous les citoyens,
y compris ceux qui travaillent
à la police.
Regardons autre chose publié
quasi en même temps
que la vidéo d’un policier
qui joue au foot.
(Vidéo) Son de sirènes.
(Voix off) Voilà à quoi ressemble
un beau dimanche ensoleillé à Bruxelles.
Ça part en arrestation hyper salée
à cause de mon port du masque.
(Témoin) Une personne fumait,
donc forcément sans son masque.
Et ils l’ont embarqué tout simplement,
directement les menottes aux poignets.
(Policier) Tout le monde circule !
(Voix off) Franchement, il forçait trop,
il exagérait complètement.
Il n’arrêtait pas de gueuler
au visage des gens
et forcément, il poussait aussi.
Après,  ils ont ramené les chiens
pour nous disperser
alors qu’on était juste assis à deux.
Ils ont complètement abusé
de leur pouvoir.
Tu connais cinq voitures de police
et tout ce cirque pour un gars qui fume ?
Ces images sont là pour dénoncer
une fois de plus un abus de pouvoir
contre une personne qui n’a
absolument rien fait de mal.
(Fin de la vidéo)
Que voyons-nous sur cette vidéo ?
Pouvons-nous en vérifier le contenu ?
La violence utilisée
par la police est-elle légale ?
La violence est-elle proportionnelle
à la menace et quelle était la menace ?
J’ai plus de questions que de réponses.
Mais je suis certain que nous avons
tous ressenti quelque chose
en regardant cette vidéo.
Que ce soit la sympathie pour la police
qui essaye de faire son travail,
ou de la sympathie pour le citoyen
qui essaye de défendre ses droits.
On a tous ressenti quelque chose.
Et puis on réagit
et on passe à autre chose.
Et la communication officielle
de la police est un bon exemple de ça.
Parce que, selon la police,
cette intervention s’est déroulée
dans le respect du cadre légal.
Mais avec 38 likes
contre 80 000 likes pour la vidéo,
je ne suis pas convaincu
qu’on a atteint tout le monde.
De surcroît, l’image de la police est
influencée par ce qui se passe ailleurs.
Ce n’est pas limité
par les frontières nationales.
Aujourd’hui, je suis jugé en fonction du
comportement d’un collègue à l’étranger.
Et je comprends d’où ça vient,
mais personnellement,
je ne trouve pas ça juste.
Dois-je vraiment évaluer chaque médecin
en fonction de la pire des expériences
que j’ai déjà eue dans un hôpital ?
Alors j’ai une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour les médecins
car vous devez tous retourner à l’école.
l’école de politesse, en premier lieu.
Mais maintenant, il faut qu’on s’oriente
vers une solution.
Comment y faire face ?
Et j'ai quelques pistes.
Serait-ce une idée d’interdire toute
participation de la part de la police
et des policiers sur les réseaux sociaux ?
Honnêtement, je ne suis pas convaincu.
Une police orientée vers la communauté,
elle est au cœur de sa population.
Elle cherche le dialogue
plutôt que de l’éviter.
N’oublions pas non plus
que le garçon ou la fille de 13 ans
qui est sur TikTok aujourd’hui
peut devenir mon collègue dans cinq ans.
Donc, dans ce cas, je préfère que cette
personne sache ce que la police représente
et ce qu’elle ne représente pas.
Deuxième possibilité : punir
plus sévèrement, des peines plus sévères ?
Je ne suis pas convaincu non plus
parce qu’une personne qui ne fait pas
quelque chose par peur de la punition,
c’est quelqu’un qui n’a pas compris
le message.
Quand on retire cette punition,
le mauvais comportement reprend.
Et donc, que faut-il faire ?
Il faut convaincre personne par personne
et pour ceux qui n’ont toujours pas
compris, on garde la punition derrière.
Et pour convaincre,
nous avons besoin du dialogue
entre la police et la population.
Mais au bon moment, pas seulement
quand les choses vont mal.
Je parle d’expérience.
Une personne qui vient
de recevoir une amende,
n’est pas très réceptive au dialogue
et pas facile à convaincre.
Donc, il faut choisir ses moments.
Mais le dialogue, il peut se
faire aussi en interne.
Nous, à la police, on doit oser
se remettre en question,
discuter de la dernière intervention
et regarder où il y a des points
d’amélioration,
Et ça peut se faire à petite échelle,
dans une voiture ou avec
mon collègue sur le vélo,
ou au niveau de l’équipe.
mais je regarde aussi
en direction de la hiérarchie
pour me créer un climat de confiance dans
lequel les erreurs peuvent être discutées.
Une deuxième chose dont on a besoin,
c’est l’accompagnement,
parce que la communication
et les réseaux sociaux se sont imposés
dans chaque domaine.
Ce n’est plus quelque chose que
l’on peut regarder de façon séparée.
Et la communication et l’éthique
doivent devenir le fil conducteur
de chaque formation policière.
Mais je regarde aussi
en direction de la société
parce que, honnêtement,
je ne trouverai jamais normal
que, quand mon fils regarde
quelque chose sur son téléphone,
il prenne ça tout de suite
pour la vérité.
Donc, les écoles, mais aussi les parents,
ont un rôle indispensable
pour préparer leurs enfants à ce
qu’ils peuvent voir sur leur téléphone
et comment y faire face.
Et troisième chose,
c’est la participation.
Quand on crée le dialogue
avec les citoyens,
il y a moyen de les responsabiliser.
Ça ne serait pas la première fois
que je demande à un citoyen
de surveiller un problème
qu’il m’a lui-même signalé.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’un citoyen a un avantage
concurrentiel sur la police :
il est H24, 7 jours sur 7, dans sa rue,
dans son quartier.
Le policier, lui, après son service,
il rentre chez lui.
Donc, on va utiliser cet avantage.
Et encore aujourd’hui, je suis étonné
à quel point les citoyens s’engagent
et sont impliqués à lutter avec la police
contre des problèmes de qualité de vie.
Et donc, en fait, ma question
pour vous, c’est :
Êtes-vous prêts, ensemble,
avec des citoyens
et déjà de nombreux collègues, à appuyer
sur le bouton «Start» avec moi ?
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)